sí
voy a enseñar a identificar las puertas
de oportunidad cuando se les presentan
pero para eso el día de hoy creo que
ustedes sepan que son abejas sí así es
el día de hoy ustedes son abejas y se
cuando llegas a las oficinas de la nasa
a la entrada hay un pequeño póster que
dice lo siguiente según estudios que se
avalan con la física y la aerodinámica
las abejas no deberían de poder volar
esto debido a que su cuerpo es demasiado
pesado como para poder ser elevado por
sus livianas alas o dicho de otra manera
las alas no son lo suficientemente
resistentes o fuertes como para poder
elevar el peso de la abeja sin embargo
todos sabemos que las abejas vuelan y no
sólo eso sino que recientes estudios
científicos han avalado y considerado
que es uno de los seres vivos más
importantes del planeta tú eres uno de
los seres vivos más importantes del
planeta tú eres una abeja pero bueno
regresando al tema de las abejas
contemplamos que según nuestros estudios
las abejas no deberían de poder volar
sin embargo todos sabemos que las abejas
vuelan y hacen un excelente trabajo de
polinización en el mundo pero por qué
porque las abejas no se ponen a
contemplar esos estudios que revelan que
ellas no deberían de poder hablar de
acuerdo a sus capacidades ellas
simplemente tienen en mente que tienen
que llegar esa flor voltean saben que
tienen un par de alas allá atrás y las
empiezan a mover para llegar a sus
objetivos y lo mismo debe de pasar
contigo debes de dejar de ver las
limitaciones en tus capacidades en tus
dones en tus prioridades y en lo que tú
quieres lograr para que empieces a salir
de tu zona de confort y es ahí donde tú
vas a descubrir que tus alas o sea tus
capacidades tus dones tus talentos todo
aquello que sea que se te ha sido dado
es más fuerte más poderoso y más capaz
de lo que tú o los demás jamás llegaron
a pensar tu eres capaz de lograr
resultados que van a demostrarle al
mundo que puedes lograr aquello que se
te había dicho que iba a ser
imposible y también vas a empezar a
entender que para ti nada es imposible
hace aproximadamente año y medio me
encontraba en la planificación de un
proyecto que iba a poder potencializar
mis prioridades para lograr las dos
cosas que más me gusta hacer en un nuevo
nivel internacional la primera de ellas
es crear porque tengo un taller de arte
tengo un estudio de arte y la segunda es
ayudar porque en la actualidad decido
capaz de poder dirigir distintos
proyectos sociales en los que hemos
podido ayudar a cientos de personas
alrededor del país pero pensé que llega
un momento importante como para pensar
en llevar esto a un nuevo nivel en poder
llevar esto a nuevos países a nuevos
lugares a nuevos límites y según mis
trazos según mis cálculos voy a poder
lograr esto aproximadamente en el
transcurso mínimo de un año no sabiendo
que cuatro meses después me iba a
encontrar atorado cansado y desgastado
en un aeropuerto después de haber pasado
más de 8 o 10 horas ahí debido a que el
mal clima no dejaba que me entregaran mi
ticket
para poder despegar a mi destino se
resolvió el problema ya venía pego cios
o lo que quería era dormirme en la
ventana de ese avión cuando se sienta un
increíble ser humano mi izquierda y me
empieza a hacer plática durante todo el
vuelo entonces igualmente que yo tenía
dos opciones la primera es hoy con todo
respeto estoy cansado creo que voy a
proceder a dormirme o continuar la
conversación con esta persona pues
pasaron diez minutos 15-20 seguimos
platicando y la conversación es que la
verdad se puso bastante buena de pronto
se hizo un silencio nadie dijo nada me
empecé a acomodar para quedarme dormido
y la persona baja a la repisa del
asiento de enfrente pone su computadora
la abre y me dice quiero mostrarte algo
y yo dije bueno está bien ya no voy a
dormir nada en este vuelo resulta que
estaba platicando con el líder de un
proyecto de impacto internacional que
hace cruzadas de eeuu a la india para
ayudar no sólo a cientos sino a que
miles de niños jóvenes y adultos en este
país en el norte centro y sur todos los
años y me invita o me abre una puerta
oportunidad para que mi proyecto
artístico social forme parte de esto de
pronto me dice que hay espacio para que
nosotros vayamos una cruzada que va a
durar aproximadamente un año un proyecto
en el que vamos a tener que dar pláticas
creativas multinacionales y de
emprendimiento de distintas personas en
el que se va a tener que imprimir un
diseño de imagen que yo iba a poder
realizar en playeras en calzado y en
distintos accesorios para donarlos a
estas instituciones que buscaban un
mejor fin para estas comunidades de
niños
yo dije este excelente seré el trato con
esta persona nos intercambiamos los
datos y al aterrizar me dice nos vemos
en tres meses
y dije ah pues perfecto en dónde va a
ser la junta para seguir planificando
todo esto dice no en tres meses ya
tenemos que estar en la india trabajando
y dije como que en tres meses pues si yo
pensaba que esto se iba a hacer en el
proceso de un año porque esos eran mis
planes eso era lo que mis alas me habían
indicado que iba a poder lograr de
acuerdo a mis capacidades de abeja y ahí
igualmente otra vez yo tengo dos
opciones la primera es determinar que no
lo va a poder lograr porque yo no era
capaz de hacer eso o entender que iba a
tener que entrar en un proceso de
sacrificio paciencia y liderazgo para
lograr algo que yo había contemplado en
un año para hacerlo en una cuarta parte
de tiempo y esto es más o menos lo que
se tenía que hacer se tienen que
desarrollar las pláticas se tienen que
generar los ingresos para mis viáticos y
para regalar esos servicios que vamos a
distribuir se tenía que generar el
diseño de imagen para imprimir estos
proyectos que se iban a regalar y muchas
otras cosas que incluían a perder es
aprenderse un par de palabras en otro
idioma para poder generar empatía en
estos foros que en muchas ocasiones no
iban a ser solamente de niños sino de
en la materia del emprendimiento de lo
que íbamos a hablar pasó el tiempo y
logramos aterrizar de manera exitosa ese
proyecto impactando a más de 5000
personas entonces para nosotros lograr
algo debemos entender que vamos a salir
de nuestra zona de confort y es ahí
donde nuestras capacidades nuestros
dones y talentos se van a fortalecer
esas salas van a volar hasta la flor más
lejana de acuerdo a lo que tú quieras
lograr y ojo que no estamos hablando
únicamente de emprendimiento estamos
hablando a lo mejor de generar un hábito
de conocer mejor una persona o en
términos generales pues y de empezar un
proyecto que te pueda dejar algo
lucrativo pero para entender que quieres
lograr algo debes de decidir tú abeja lo
que quieres lograr porque si le
preguntas a la abeja de la derecha o de
la izquierda acerca de tu proyecto la
opinión que ellos te den no va a ser de
acuerdo a lo que tú quieres lograr la
abeja de la derecha ama las manzanas
la abeja de la izquierda ama las peras
tú odias las frutas la visión de la
abeja de la izquierda no es la misma
visión que la abeja de la derecha el
único que puede entender el verdadero
potencial de la idea o del proyecto que
tú tienes eres tú porque el único que va
a desarrollar y realizar ese proyecto en
tu vida eres tú entonces no seas el tipo
de abeja que no hace un proyecto por la
opinión ajena porque si tú realmente
estás dispuesto a sacrificar tu tiempo
para lograr lo que quieres debes estar
seguro de que lo que tú vas a hacer va a
funcionar debes de tener amor por tu
proyecto paz por tu proyecto pasión por
tu proyecto mansedumbre por tu proyecto
si regresáramos ahorita 300 años en el
tiempo y tú me dijeras que va a inventar
un aparato para poderte comunicar con
cualquier persona en tiempo real
alrededor del planeta el 99% de la
población humana te ha dicho
estás loco no lo vas a poder lograr y
sin embargo en este día estamos teniendo
esta plática a través del uso de las
redes en las telecomunicaciones no seas
tú es abeja que tuvo una idea y que no
logró impactar al mundo por escuchar los
demás muchas gracias
esta fue mi plática